okay a couple of other quick stories
that we've been covering the alex jones
text messages have made their way to the
trump riot committee based on reporting
from a number of different sources so
let's back up and to remind you what's
going on
we knew before the alex jones defamation
trial that jones was involved and in
contact with uh people that were
organizing and at the trump riots on
january 6 2021.
we
knew that it would be great if alex
jones was somehow more involved in under
scrutiny from the january 6 committee
but it wasn't clear if and how that was
going to happen then the alex jones
defamation trial took place and as you
might remember alex jones own boneheaded
lawyer
accidentally sent
a full digital copy
of jones entire mobile phone including
text messages and other things to the
attorney representing the plaintiffs in
the defamation trial and there was
cartoonish stuff in there like for
example
there was a record of alex jones sending
according to the plaintiff's attorney
alex jones sent a naked picture of his
own wife
to roger stone like bizarre cartoonish
stuff
but also because of the timeline of
those text messages in that digital copy
it was reasonable to believe or to
expect or to wonder
that materials related to january 6 also
would have been on that digital copy and
then we learned the january 6 committee
wants alex jones text messages and now
the reporting from cnn is alex jones
texts have been turned over to the
january 6 committee the article reads
approximately two years worth of text
messages sent and received by conspiracy
theorist alex jones have been turned
over to the house select committee
investigating the january 6th
insurrection a person familiar with the
matter said to cnn
the messages were handed over to the
committee by mark bankston the attorney
who represented the sandy hook parents
who successfully sued jones in texas and
won nearly 50 million dollars in the
civil trial bankston would only tell cnn
that he is cooperating with the
committee the committee declined to
comment during the trial as you might
recall bankston revealed one of jones
lawyers messed up and inadvertently sent
him the two years of text messages that
bankston uh and bankston also said
during the trial the committee expressed
interest in the material you know it's a
really good thing
that so many of the people
behind january 6th
involved in january 6 and in this case
representing individuals involved with
january 6 speaking of course of alex
jones attorney
are kind of doofuses it's very useful
and it aids the investigation to proceed
that a lot of these people don't seem to
be playing with a full deck or you know
uh the wheel is spinning but the
hamster's dead whatever metaphor or
phrase you want to apply to it now none
of this means that there are going to be
consequences i think as we now have
learned of the fbi raid of donald
trump's mar-a-lago home
it's entertaining
it feels like at least he's suffering a
little because they raided his home but
i am not assuming that trump is going to
be indicted or that if he is that there
will be consequences
we will have to wait and see and
similarly
the fact that the committee now has the
text messages of alex jones
even though it was not jones intention
for the committee to have them it
doesn't necessarily mean that there's
going to be consequences now one of the
things that
uh
is important to remember is anytime
you're dealing with leaks or transfers
of information
the right wingers love to pull this
double standard when it came to the
hunter biden laptop they didn't care
how the blind computer tech got it
they didn't care about anything in terms
of due process or discovery or finding
it it didn't matter it was what's on the
laptop
now they're saying what hold on a second
what about due process this was an
accident what about attorney-client
privilege what about invasion of privacy
what about free speech they'll throw
whatever they can at the wall to say the
content of the text messages does not
matter all that matters is how did the
january 6 committee obtain the text
messages predictable people we will see
what happens and what the next step is
in terms of the committee and alex jones
remember the committee expected to hold
more hearings i believe they said in
september so we will see